Speaker 1: All right, so now let's get to
that story that I alluded to earlier.
Dozens of you emailing me and saying, David,
what is happening?
Tulsi Gabbard is speaking at C-PAC, the Conservative
Political Action Conference.
What the hell is going on here?
Let's discuss it.
This weekend actually started starting Thursday
night and our coverage will start Thursday
as well.
CPAC is happening in Florida.
CPAC, the Conservative Political Action Conference,
is a sort of who's who of Republicans, right
wing extremists, religious conservatives,
conspiracy theorists and all of these other
different aspects of the American right wing.
And as a guest, they are having former Democratic
congresswoman, former Democratic presidential
candidate Tulsi Gabbard, who I thought was
on the left.
And in fact, while she was running in the
Democratic primary, you had people who said
this is the only true liberal left.
This is the only true leftist left because
people fell for it, she would say regime change
wars and endless wars, and people would say,
Oh, she's so great, she's so fantastic.
Notice that CPAC promotion of Tulsi doesn't
even mention that she was a Democratic presidential
candidate.
It doesn't say that she was a Democratic congresswoman.
It just says presidential candidate and people
fell for this stuff.
I didn't, and you all know that, and some
of you did.
And I told you day after day, you're being
tricked.
Don't fall for it, don't fall for it.
The buzzwords she would use would make leftists
some leftists fawn all over her.
She's against wars and stuff, so she's good.
And I'd criticize her and I'd be called the
DNC tool and a DNC plant.
And part of the concerted effort to take away
attention from Tulsi or whatever.
In fact, I did quite the opposite.
Even by just talking about her.
Most of my audience was like, David, she's
completely irrelevant to this race.
Why are you even talking about her?
And it was because, you know, people were
telling me some people were saying, David,
she's the only real liberal.
She has a much better shot of winning the
Republican nomination than the Democratic
nomination.
And I am issuing a call right now to the people
who got bamboozled by her.
Just stand up and say, I got tricked.
I'm going to do better next time.
It's OK.
Just admit it.
It happens to all of us.
But I also want to include something serious
on this.
It's not just about we were obviously right
about to see.
It's not OK.
There's a very good tweet that our friend
Farron Cousins from Ring of Fire put out about
CPAC and he said, quote, We're all going to
spend the next week mocking C-PAC while ignoring
the fact that we don't have the level of organization
or attention.
We don't have that level of organization or
attention on the left.
We're at a tremendous disadvantage.
And that rarely gets mentioned.
And Farron is exactly right.
I've been screaming for a decade.
They are better than us at this.
They are better than us.
The left barely even funds independent media,
never mind something like CPAC.
The right understands you've got to pour money
into on campus stuff.
You've got to pour money into.
Young professionals and getting them over
to your way of thinking.
You've got to have events.
You've got to have people who feel like they're
part of something.
You've got to fund media.
They fund Turning Point USA and all sorts
of different right wing shows.
We have almost none of it on the left, and
they love to say, Oh, but George Soros is
pouring money into this, that the other thing,
et cetera, et cetera.
The left barely funds this type of stuff in
the right way.
And when I talk about, hey, you know, like
only half of one percent of our audience is
our members on our website.
I'm not just saying, Hey, it'd be cool if
you supported our work.
I'm also saying at a certain point, we've
got to fund the things that we think are important
and having a big infrastructure of right wing
media and right wing activism all coming together
is a really big deal for the right.
It just is.
There's no way around it.
There's this conference Netroots Nation I
used to go to on the left, and I think it's
like the biggest thing the left has.
And it's it's not great.
You know, I have friends who still work over
there.
It's not great.
First of all, you know how I often say to
you guys, these little toxic elements of the
left are very, very small, like the the right
loves to say, Oh, the left is all identity
politics and woke stirrers and all this different
stuff.
And I explain to you, it's actually really
small netroots, which was like the only thing
we had unfortunately overrepresented some
of those toxic elements of the left.
I don't even know if Netroots still exists.
I know they did some online only stuff, but
like if that's the best we have and the right
has CPAC turning point USA, all of these different
think tanks, and they're so well-funded, how
can we hope to compete?
So yes, we are going to ridicule the things
said at CPAC.
I will be live with CPAC coverage Thursday,
Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
It's going to be a huge weekend of insanity.
We're going to laugh at it.
It's going to be funny to some degree.
But in the back of it, we have to remember
they are so much better organized than we
are.
And unless we can get it together, even though
the country keeps moving to the left, the
electorate keeps moving to the left.
If you look at issues, they're going to keep
winning, they're going to keep winning and
we need to understand that